i'm obsessed with names and i think one
of the coolest things to look at is one
original name and see all the variations
that spawned over time let's do an
example the name is elisheva you might
not have heard of it it's from the old
testament except you definitely have
because in english it's elizabeth or
elizabeta or elsbeth oh yeah also
isabelle and isabella maybe you're more
of a fan of a shortened form of
elizabeth from the beginning of the name
we have eliza elsa ellie ella isa izzy
lisa from the middle of the name we get
babette and libby and from the back half
of the name bella betty bess beth betsy
even buffy and all of those names come
from one name elysheva and there's so
many other examples of names like this
today we're looking at the name john and
i'm a little bit stressed to be clear we
are not looking at the name jonathan
today the source of both names is the
hebrew from the bible but jonathan is
yonatan and john is yochanan so we're
looking at yochanan the first
translation i found was greek and it's
ilanus this goes to johannes in german
ivan and slavic languages and giovanni
and italian juan and spanish joao and
portuguese and jonas in lithuanian in
the british isles we got ian evan ewan
and ethan for a little rhyming moment
jean and french and sean and irish
shortened verses include hans in german
yani and greek and my favorite nino in
italian in english we have the nickname
jack this name was also highly feminized
feminized versions include joanna joanne
jean joan jeannette janet janice ivana
ivanka giovanna kwana sinead shauna and
siobhan and that's the tip of the
iceberg
today we're talking about the very
popular trend of using surnames as first
names many popular names today are
actually names that originated as
surnames or last names and this dates
all the way back to the tudor era in
england when people would name their
children after the last names of
nobility now onto some popular names
that originated as surnames first is the
name taylor this comes from an english
surname meaning taylor somebody who
makes clothes mallory is an english
surname that comes from a norman french
meaning unfortunate blake also derived
from an english surname but it might
have come from the word blake meaning
black or the word black which meant pale
madison comes from an english surname
meaning son of mod and yes it became
popular as a girl's name after the movie
splash ashley derived from an english
surname that itself derived from an
english place name meaning ash tree
clearing avery came from a norman french
surname that itself was derived from the
given name albrecht or alfred mckenzie
derives from the scottish last name matt
cognac which meant son of kanye and
harper is an english surname that
originally meant somebody who makes
warps
today we are finally covering alexander
this name comes from the greek
alexandros which meant defending men now
if we just take that basic form
alexander or alexander you can shorten
it into al alec alex sander or xander
other diminutives include sonia and
sasha in russian olek in polish alecos
in greek and sasa and ale in many
different languages in terms of language
variation there's iskander in arabic
alistair and scottish alessandro in
italian and alejandro in spanish there's
also alexander and ukrainian there's way
more but let's get into the feminized
forms there's pretty much a feminized
form of alexander in every language so
there's alexandra alexandria alexandrina
alejandra alessandra and alexandra and
shortened forms include alexa lexi andra
and sandra there you go the much
requested alexander
[Music]
you